what the S EP brings is really
liberating in terms of thinking whether
it was on the marketing side customer
intimacy customer profitability whether
it was financed cash flow statements and
all that I mean there was something
there on all sides the beauty of it all
is trying to bring it all in together
and to integrate it into your mind about
the key things you need to think about
when you're leading businesses there was
a lot of emphasis in the SCP on culture
and building a culture that's supportive
and innovative when I got the cafe we
decided to do a survey to see what
people thought about our culture that
the first results were we're not very
encouraging to tell you the truth there
was a lot of work to be done that we
developed the plan and thought about how
we can improve that well two years later
and the stick the company who did it
came back to us and said this is
impossible you've gone from you know
almost the lowest we've ever seen to the
highest we've ever seen you know in one
go and all that was just applying some
of the concepts and ideas that I learned
here Robert Byrd woman especially
emphasized news for strategic
imperatives that you have to do when
you're running a business I put this
model on my board and i look at it once
a month and ask myself am i doing all
those things just having that as a
thought process as a mental model to to
think through your challenges has been
amazingly valuable for me from our point
of view vs CP it really works it
delivers great value and it's something
that we've been doing for more than 20
years and certainly will be intending to
do going forward
you